hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast advances in laboratory
freeze-drying presented by kelly
williams and jenny sprung we're excited
to bring you this educational web
seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by lab con co serving in the
scientific community since 1925 lab
concur manufactures laboratory equipment
specializing in ventilation products
such as chemical fume hoods and
biological safety cabinets they also
produce other equipment such as glass
air washers and freeze dryers for the
lab lab con co has ISO 9001
certification one measure of the
company's commitment to quality and
consistency in design and manufacturing
lab kanto equipment is manufactured in
Kansas City Missouri and Fort Scott
Kansas and marketed worldwide to
academic industrial life science
pharmaceutical environmental forensic
and clinical laboratories to learn more
about lab concho
please visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on your screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
finally if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or you can use
the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem thank you before
you eat the speakers poll questions on
your
you may select an answer or close the
poll question by clicking on the X in
the right course thank you and the
question is are you currently Y
alkalizing freeze-drying in your
laboratory to take a moment to to answer
now I'd like to introduce our speakers
kelly williams is a product manager for
freeze dryers and evaporators at lab
conk oh she has helped lab Congo
customers with their application and
equipment needs for more than 17 years
Kelly has a BA in biology and an mba in
marketing prior to working with lab
Kronk Oh Kelly conducted endocrinology
research in a biochemistry lab Jenny
sprung is a senior application
specialist at lab Khan Co with emphasis
on evaporation and lyophilization
glassware washers water and forensic
products
she also covers all of lab không có 17
product lines jenny has a BS in biology
with a minor in chemistry prior to
working at lab Khan Co she worked at MC
Johnson wax in sensory marketing please
join me in welcoming Kelly Williams I
will now turn the presentation over to
her thank you Judy thank you for joining
us today we are going to speak
specifically on laboratory freeze drying
and the advances that are happening in
laboratory freeze drying but as we go
over the process in general how to
develop a protocol deal with challenging
samples and also troubleshooting so this
will give you a really good background
on an overview on free shrine in what is
it has been happening also in the
presentation we'll go over some
definitions if you're not really
familiar with free strong there there is
terminology specific to the application
and it's nice to understand that so many
people wonder is free strong with the
difference between free strong and
lyophilization and there really isn't a
difference they're the same process and
this process is is undergoes what a
condition called sublimation
in in sublimation that is simply where
you're solvent such as water or can be
other solvents passed directly from the
solid to the vapor state and that is
what makes freeze drawing very unique
compared to evaporation or other
processes and we'll go over what is
required to actually sublimate in the
type of equipment that is needed and
some of the advances that are helping
speed the sublimation rate and also give
more consistency and quality to the
whole freeze drying process but in
general three strong Ally authorization
the exact same thing lots of times I
alkalization is more of a scientific
application where freeze drying can be
more for food or that type of stuff that
they're used interchangeably when we are
talking about sublimation this rate of
sublimation in other words how fast the
fre strongest is occurring is dependent
on temperature and pressure and if you
can look at this chart this is a great
chart to show the difference in in
between freeze drying or sublimation and
evaporation in sublimation we're going
straight from a solid to a gas you do
not want to pass through the liquid
phase so in evaporation we're going from
a solid or liquid to a gas it's more
from a liquid to a gas so you can
actually go through three different
phases but the thing that is very
critical that keeps make sure that there
is a difference between the two is what
is called the triple point and at that
triple point is the is the highest
temperature that a sample can exist at
without going through sublimation so in
other words you want to keep that
temperature or also keep the pressure so
that the temperature is there below the
triple point to ensure that you're going
through sublimation and not evaporation
we're going to go over the life of a
ssin process the first thing that the
life was a ssin process required
the pre frozen sample this is what the
first four items that are required it's
very important that that sample is
frozen and frozen solid in laboratories
many times the samples are aqueous
however there could be other solvents
involved in error mixed in with the
sample one thing we encourage people to
do if it is possible for you to get rid
of the other solvents before you three
stri if it is not possible then you are
going to have to address those other
solvents and make sure that your freeze
dryer is cold enough to accommodate
those the second requirement of a free
Schreyer is a collector that is 15 to 20
degrees Celsius colder than the sample
freezing point this is the main driver
of the freeze drying and it is critical
so if you are trying to pre shy a sample
that has a has a lower freezing point
and your collector is not cold enough
that is going to be a challenge so you
need that Delta that change of that
temperature degrees in your collector
when free shrine also if you do have a
freeze dryer a lots of times people have
free showers in their labs for 25-30
years you're going to want to make sure
that it continues to get to the to the
temperatures that it's supposed to be
operating at as they loose gaps or over
time they may their temperature of the
collectors may start to become elevated
and it's critical that you make sure
that they stay cold the third
requirement of freeze drying is a deep
vacuum and you need to vacuum with a
minimum requirement of two times ten to
the minus three millibars there have
been advances in vacuums tops and we'll
get will go over that in more detail but
there are several new pumps out that
make the maintenance of the pump easier
and will still reach that deep vacuum
meditated after you
years of experience in free shrine many
times if you ask Jenny and I we would
probably say the most difficult things
work for people that are free shrine is
to maintain their pumps and to maintain
those deep vacuums the last the fourth
the last thing that is needed for free
shrine is energy in the form of heat and
a lot of people don't realize this
because here you have a frozen product
and you want it to keep frozen you want
it to stay frozen however the heat is
what is really driving that process and
he is certainly variable it is going to
be determinants of how long your free
shrine process takes and also the
quality of the final product the heat
input there's a trade-off between speed
and quality for some samples so a lot of
this when you're developing a protocol
the heat input can be a lot of trial and
error or you can do some investigation
ahead of time to help you get closer to
where you need to be as far as the heat
input and we're going to go over these
four things more in depth as they relate
to freeze drying a lot of times people
think that when they're in the
laboratory flasks free strong is very
common and so they have a flask sitting
out attached to their pre shire in the
lab and they don't realize that heat is
going in from the room where the room is
at 25 degrees C and heat is indeed going
into that sample so so you are getting
heat there even though you think it's
just a flat sitting there the heat input
is there other things that to consider
in your laboratory when your freeze
drying as far as heat to your flask is
that is your sample we we will have
end-users call us because some of their
samples are melting back and some of
their that them are not and they're all
on the same drawing chamber and they're
the same sample but many times a sample
could be overhanging where their vacuum
pump is or
putting out a lot of meat or that sample
could be by a window where it is it is
getting more heat so heat is important
and it is affecting even flat free
shrine where the heat is more controlled
and visible is when you are freeze
drying on shelves particularly
temperature controlled shelves you can
many shelves can be cooled as well so
you can pre freeze on these shelves or
heat on the shelves and there's also
heated shelves and clear cylinders so
the shelf
freeze drying gives you more control
over the heat than the flat freeze
drying and you are getting all sorts of
heat you're getting conductive
convective and radiant heat but that by
far the most common is the conductive
where it's getting picking up the heat
right from the shelves but certainly
there has been investigation into
conductive heat in its role as free
strong as as well as radiant heat but
when we talk heat the most common is the
convective or the conductive the free
strong process can be broken down into
three three separate stages and we'll go
through in in depth these stages you
have your pre freezing stage your
primary drying stage and your secondary
drying stage and your all of these
stages can be if you are charting your
product temperature can be during the
process can be identified on charts the
first one your freezing you will notice
that your sample temperature will and if
you're looking at the chart the green
line is your product temperature where
the blue line is your cynical or your
your shelf temperature so your shelf
temperature is dropping and you will
know
is that where the point where the the
product temperature equals the shelf
temperature is where your freezing is
occurring after you've reached your
sample is frozen the shelves will begin
to heat up however you will not note you
will notice there's not a direct
correlation there in your product
temperature your product temperature
will certainly lag you're black your
shelf temperature and in that phase
where the primary temperature or the
temperature of your sample is below your
shelf temperature because of evaporative
cooling that is where the majority of
the water or solvent is removed from
your sample so that is in the primary
drying phase where most of the work of
the freeze dryer is being done and it is
certainly the longest phase in the
freeze drying process that primary
drying phase follows the freezing of it
and will continue until you will notice
that your your product temperature
equals your shelf temperature so for
many customers who are not going into or
interested in long-term storage of their
samples they would pretty much consider
that the prop freeze drying process done
after primary drying for customers that
are interested or need to get down to
very interested in long-term storage or
ones that need to get down to very low
moisture content in the remaining sample
they will undergoing undergo secondary
drying and it is in secondary drawing
where more heat is needed to drive off
the bound water molecules so during
primary drawing the water molecules are
removed and they are the molecule the
water molecules in your sample and
secondary trying the water molecules
that are removed are actually bound to
your sample and will require a little
bit more heat input to break those bonds
because
the majority of the water has been earth
solvent has been removed during
secondary drying you can raise the
temperature on the sample without fear
of collapse of your own melt back
collapse and melt back are pretty much
the same thing again here is a graph of
the freezing of your sample and you can
tell when freezing occurs for many
samples because it will take a dive and
income the temperature will dive low and
then come back just the tiny bit some
terminology that is used in the pre
freezing process is the eutectic
temperature it's the temperature when
all of the eutectic makes sure both the
solvents in the solvents is frozen and
you're going to want to make sure that
your sample is thoroughly frozen before
you freeze dry and then it does not
start melting before you pull your
vacuum you want to get your sample
loaded in the vacuum drawn before you
before you start having melt back or if
you are free strong on shelves and you
are not able to and they are not able to
be temperature controlled or cooled
you're going to want to put that shelf
in the freezer with your sample so you
want to maintain that sample temperature
cold and in for some systems that may
take several minutes for the vacuum to
get pulled down and once the vacuum is
pulled down you're going to start freeze
drying and you in the sublimation
process will provide evaporative cooling
your sample will begin to cool and
that's what will keep your sample frozen
so if you are freeze drying on shelves
so they are not temperature controlled
you will want to freeze that shelf with
your sample there have been some
advancements in the pre freezing part of
free strong and that's for a lot of the
research over the past five to seven
years has occurred in what they are
finding is that how you pre freeze can
have it
fact certainly on your final product but
it will definitely affect the rate of
priests trying but how you how those
crystals are form and the sizes of the
crystals will will have an effect on the
rate of sublimation for many samples the
fastest rate of evaporation or
sublimation is going to occur when the
the crystal sizes are large large
crystal sizes when you're pre freezing
will leave you with a more porous cake
which will allow the vapor molecules to
leave the sample more easily when you
have very small pores the it's a lot
harder for the vapor molecules to leave
your sample so one thing that has gotten
pretty common in the pre freezing is a
step called annealing and annealing is
the process cycling the product
temperature to optimize the large
crystal growth for shorter drying times
and not only will annealing decrease
your drawing times it will also
standardize your samples believe it or
not when you're pretty freezing and you
have a shelf full of samples for you
would think if you're not very
experienced you would think that as soon
as that we reached our eutectic point
all our samples will freeze and it would
happen simultaneously but in actuality
the freezing and the crystallization of
the sample is very random and and so you
may have one sample freeze way before
another one and so it's a very random
process and annealing will standardize
that process and what how you anneal is
you simply lower the product temperature
and then when it and low enough that all
your samples freeze and after they're
frozen you have been raise your
temperature to a higher temperature for
a few hours and generally that higher
temperature is about three to four
degrees below the eutectic
point so you're not raising the
temperature high enough for it to melt
but you are raising it to a higher
temperature for a few hours
and then you're bringing it back down
and it's pretty amazing how that will
standardize to all the samples to have
the tutee have a very similar crystal
sizes as well as sublimation rates or
the time required for freeze drying
here's the view of the effects of
crystal size and you can see that the
larger crystals are the smaller crystals
on the Left how it would be harder for
vapour molecules to pass through that
frozen cake as your sample on sublimates
or free strides it's going to move
through your samples generally from the
top to the bottom and so as you go into
the middle or to the bottom the
molecules food to leave your sample have
to pass through with already been
freeze-dried so the larger crystal size
will leave on larger pore sizes in this
world this can be achieved with
annealing what we're talking pre
freezing a lot of people in laboratories
are doing flash freezing and one thing
that we highly encourage our shell
freezing and you can see the sample
there on the right is shell frozen you
can see that the sample has been turned
and and here's a picture of a shell
freezer the sample has been turned and
so that the sample has been distributed
against the side walls and a nice thin
coating other suggestions that we
suggest are sub-freezing when you step
freeze your sample is put at an angle
and both of these have the sole purpose
of increasing the surface area the step
freezing on the left is not recommended
that will give you the least amount of
surface area that there is and also may
end up in breaking your flasks is too
much pressure is put on that glass in
specific spots so slant freezing to at
the very minimum or shelf freezing are
recommended to to just simply decrease
the rate at the evaporation one thing
that has gotten common for freeze drying
if you're if you're free sharing a
highly valuable sample or you're gearing
up to freeze share the same sample over
and over is the use of microscopy and
freeze drying and there are several
different organizations where you can
send your sample away and they can
actually watch the freeze drying process
under a microscope and they can give you
the specific eutectic point and also
other temperatures that you should be
aware of that are critical in your
process for the majority of people they
have to guesstimate their sample
freezing point and it's pretty easy if
you're dealing with an aqueous solution
however to get more complicated if you
have more solvents involved and in those
you're going to have to look at the
solvents in their freezing point and
look at the percentage of what they are
making up of that and get a good a
pretty good indication of what their
freezing point is here's a good picture
of primary drawing and I mentioned
earlier the evaporative cooling even
though your sample in a flask is hanging
in the room it is cold and will remain
frozen and that is because of the amount
of primary drawing that is occurring and
the molecules that are going again
primary drawing is where the majority of
the of the moisture is removed from the
sample some some definitions during
primary drawing or a critical collapse
temperature in critical collapse
temperature is the maximum temperature
that the product in with standard
primary drawing without it melting or
collapsing and for some samples they the
critical collapse temperature can be
they if you're using fast free strong
and is it is in a room you may be above
your critical collapse temperature and
even though you're not controlling that
flask there are ways to reduce that
temperature of that flask you can simply
put your sample within a flask so a
flask within a flat so that you have a
buffer area to buffer the heat that's
getting to your sample or you can add
insulation around your sample so staying
below your critical collapse temperature
is important and also how your sample
collapse is sometimes unique to your
sample some samples will undergo a glass
transition where instead of all of a
sudden melting the sample is still solid
but it becomes more flexible and that's
called the glass transition so there are
some terms for the primary drawing again
if you do have a sample and it is
critical meaning it's a sample from
physical product that's being developed
or you're gearing up to go into
production and you're going to be
running one specific sample many times
it is well worth the money to pay to
have a study done under a microscope to
know what your critical temperatures are
here is an example of what they do see
under the microscope and you can see as
the drawing front is moving across you
have your solid line and that's where
the sublimation is occurring and at the
top I'm looking at the picture on the
left you see frozen material and dried
material and a real nice solid line
that's very visible of the sublimation
rate and the photo on the right you will
see that that line
is it's not so distinct between the two
that there's kind of a group or a way
behind the sublimation line where your
sample is actually collapsing so that is
what it would look like under a
microscope if you are using a flask and
you are in primary drawing in your
sample starts to melt as you can see
here what is happening is the collector
temperature well there's many reasons
for your sample to start melting but two
of the two of the most common would be
your vacuum level is not a Mon up or
number two your collector temperature is
not cold enough so Jimmy will get over
or we'll go over what what you can do to
troubleshoot this but here is the photo
of in this collapse or melting during
primary drawing is lots of times
referred to as melt back and she will
cover exactly how we can control the
heat into a flask to prevent melt back
temperature is important and that is one
of the most important things that we
have to combat smelt back here's an
example off of a study and just a 5
degree shelf temperature difference can
have a drastic effect on your final
product and what what the role of
temperature has in the free strong
process vacuum is also another necessity
and by not having the proper vacuum then
you can also run into problems here is
some visual effects of primary drawing
how the role of vacuum and heat
determined how the final
product ended up the both of them are
very critical and can make a big
difference in your final product after
primary drawing we go into secondary
drawing and like I mentioned earlier
unless you're doing long-term storage of
your product if you're just using free
strong as a sample prep before analysis
for most people they do not need it they
do not need their sample to be down to
less than 5 degrees or 5 percent
moisture because they're going to
reality re suspend it in something else
anyway but for people that are doing
long-term storage it's critical that you
go through secondary drying and then
secondary drawing your product looks dry
however you need to add heat to that
product to to break those bonds like I
mentioned earlier endpoint determination
is toys can be tricky when freeze
drawing and if you're doing long-term
storage you're definitely going to want
to know that your product has reached
endpoint and again most for most people
at moisture level between 0.5% and 3%
Pat is what is desire in order for
long-term storage the way to determine
that you have reached endpoints are
visual inspection
you also can measure the condensable
gases versus a vacuum gauge and then you
also can do product temperature or
weight and these can get very specific
for flash freeze drying we're going to
go over a in advancement in a minute of
how to turn on the endpoint very easily
long-term storage if you're going to
store your sample long term you're going
to want to stop or under vacuum and the
best ways to do that or to use a drying
accessory that will stop or under vacuum
and in addition to the trays that are
shown here there
are also smaller wanted and less
expensive samples in order to do
long-term storage or another process is
using ant hills and flame sealing them
so both of those processes top ring and
flame ceiling will feel your sample why
it is under vacuum which is critical
because as soon as you release the
vacuum you're going to get air in there
and it's going to have moisture real
quickly going over how to pick out a
freeze dryer in this and we'll go over
some of the advances that have actually
happened in the equipment to to
accommodate different samples your first
thing is like I mentioned earlier you're
going to want to determine your
collector temperature if you have a good
idea of what your freezing - your
freezing point of your sample is then
you will know exactly what temperature
you're going to need to purchase for
most manufacturers there are three
temperatures there is a minus 50 which
is for aqueous samples among is 84 which
is for aqueous solvent mixtures and
those are higher freezing point solvents
such as a seed of nitrile and then there
are even colder collectors that will get
down to minus 105 and those are
generally if you're using methanol or
any alcohols and when we say using them
we mean dilute it has to be around five
or ten percent or less and and it will
still require the minus 105 so so it's
just based on experience we know if
you're using HPLC samples you're
probably going to have some a seated
nitrile in there and if you're using a
seat of nitrile you're going to need to
use the minus 84 if you also have
methanol in your sample you're going to
need to use a minus 105 some other type
common types of laboratory samples are
fruits and they will have sugar so
you're going to need to be concerned
about particulate soils you can also
need to be concerned about particulate
proteomics
if you're using any acids you're going
to want to take special care of your
quit equipment and and what we assigned
is for nanoparticles all the times
they're in aqueous sample as well I've
included some eutectic charts and for
common samples as well as compatibility
with parts of the freeze dryers so you
can see if you're going to need an
acrylic littered glass lid and if you're
going to need additional secondary
trapping in which type of vacuum pump so
these are occluded for you to reference
I'm not going to take the time to go
through them another thing when you're
picking out a freeze dryer is you're
going to need to determine your
collector size most freeze tires are
labeled by the size of ice capacity so
if this says it's a two and a half liter
freeze-dry er it can hold two and a half
liters of ice before it needs to be
defrosted
but however that does not mean you can
load two and a half liters of sample on
there a general rule of thumb is you're
going to want to put about half the
volume of the sample as the ice capacity
so for instance if you're running a 1
liter sample if you're going to in it
not even one liter it can be one liter
spread over 50 samples but if you add up
all the total sample volume that you're
loading you're going to want to times it
by two and at least get that large of a
collector so for instance in this
instance if we are putting 25 400 ml
samples on we're going to have about a
liter of sample and we're going to times
that by 2 and we're going to need at
least a two liter collector so our
closest fit would be a two and a half
liter freeze dryer when you are picking
out a free Strider you're also going to
want to know what samples are you
putting in there or what your solvents
are if you are you want to check and
make sure that what you're putting in
there is compatible with stainless steel
if it is not there are some acids that
are not compatible with stainless steel
when you're purchasing your freeze-dried
your want to going to get a PTFE
protection PTFE is the chemical name for
Teflon so when you're purchasing it is
is when the time you want to get that
protection this cannot be installed
later in the field so if you if there is
a chance that you're going to be using
acids you're going to want to make sure
that you order one um with that other
things to consider that we run into a
lot are lots of times a 3-star maybe a
piece of court equipment where a whole
floor is sharing it you're going to want
to know the needs of everyone that is
going to be using it and make the
purchase for everyone or what your how
your science may change in the next year
or two you may not be using acids or
solvents right now but if there's a
chance that you're going to use them in
the next in the life of the freeze dryer
it's best to make the purchase with them
because there is no going back to make
your collector colder or to add that
PTFE coating it's always very helpful to
have a clear path of who's changing
who's in charge of maintenance who's
changing the oil on the vacuum pump if
your oil if your pump does use oil we
run into core facilities where no one is
really in charge of the maintenance and
so the pump gets neglected and here is a
view of a vacuum an oil pump that was
not maintained some things that you can
do to make your oil pump last longer are
number one make sure you're looking at
the level and the quality of them and
number two when you're done using a
freeze dryer it is highly recommended to
open the gas ballast and run your vacuum
pump for at least 30 minutes to purge
the oil of any contaminants in when I've
talked contaminants water is the
contaminant because out of that oil
because what does settle into the oil if
you simply shut your freeze dryer off is
just going to sit there and corrode the
inside of your pump so a lot of people
don't think that
water is that corrosive that an
actuality for the metal in a pump water
can be very corrosive so you're going to
want to make sure that you purge that
pump of any contaminants after use
awesome no your solvents and not just
look at the pump in the collector but
also look at the glass and the rubber
components and make sure that your
sample what you're using is compatible
for those last or next you're going to
need to to pick a drawing chamber this
specific the drawing part drawing
chambers of freezer I come in many
different styles in there for tubes or
flask or ampules here's a new ampule pod
that can accommodate ampules on a
drawing chamber you can get both tray
dryers you can get clear tray gyres
product shells PETA product shelves
stopping you if you're using stop ring
and need long-term storage you can get a
stop ring tray dryer you also can get a
clear stop ring or less expensive ways
to stop or smaller samples also you can
there are equipment if you're sovereigns
you can get a shelf tray dryer
call it this one particulars called our
tray dryer where the condenser and the
trays are all in one and you can do all
sorts of different even flats freeze
drying with this unit vacuum pumps when
you're selecting a vacuum pump you're
going to need to make sure it can go to
the level the deep level that you need
and to as the instance in vacuum pumps
are a scroll vacuum pump which is a dry
vacuum pump it does not require oil or a
combination pump and that's that's a oil
pump that keeps the the oil or the head
of the the pump under vacuum which
really discourages the settlement of
samples into the oil
if you're using a hybrid vacuum pump
your maintenance is reduced about 80 to
90 percent the scroll pumps do not have
maintenance other than about every two
to three years you will have to replace
the tips on them when you're looking at
your free char in your process there's a
lot of different accessories that can
that our sample specific that can help
ease your process for instance the micro
plate holder micro plates can be
difficult to freeze-dry you can get a
slanted pre-strike holder or card or
test tube holders other things that are
available if you do have the -50
collector and all of a sudden are
running colder samples then you can use
a secondary vacuum track that would
utilize dry ice and when you're looking
at your freeze dryer some things to
consider are your coil design or your
coils exposed giving you the maximum
trapping or vapor stream trapping
ability or they behind the chamber where
they're not as efficient what kind of
controls controls have really changed
now there are touchscreen controls with
freeze dryers that can send you emails
when there is an alert or they will have
built-in processes to prevent your you
from accidentally ruining your vacuum
pop or having your samples melt back
that have elaborate programming where
you can put more steps in or pre freeze
a certain way so there have been a lot
of advancements in control and the
abilities of the freeze dryers
does your freezer I offer vacuum control
many times by controlling the vacuum you
can shave hours off of your process so
that is another advancement that that's
happened recently and just within the
past year there we have the ability now
to determine end point very easily in a
flask with an accessory called an end
point
and system this is an expensive
accessory that can go on your flasks
because part of the pot the problem with
free storing and flash because you don't
know when to start or when to stop
software and programming touch screen
remote accessibility and notification
are all advancements that have been made
and priests trying to make the process
easier I'm going to now pass it over to
Jenny who will speak about who will talk
on developing your protocol and also
some troubleshooting she's an
application specialist who who has a lot
of experience in freeze drying right
thank inherently there yep I'm here can
you offer me yes right okay
so Kelly covered the process of the
freeze dryers as well as the equipment
that's offered we're going to discuss
very quickly how to optimize your
process a couple things that you want to
consider when you're filling your
container if you purchase a six hundred
milliliter flap and you want to pre
freeze and freeze dry 600 milliliters
it's not recommended because your
glassware will break as you see in the
picture what is recommended is to fill
it about a third full and to slant or
she'll freeze as Kelly mentioned another
common way to freeze dry is to put your
samples either in test tubes or vials
and you need to make sure that you do
have a headspace within that vial there
are different types of pumps that can be
used and some people think that the
bigger the pump the better make sure
that you're looking at the manufacturers
recommendations on the minimum
requirements for the vacuum pump in
order to get the perfect pump for what
you are trying to do when you're looking
at a hybrid pump so sometimes pull a
little bit deeper so you don't need the
CFM amount that say a standard rotary
vane pump will have so what you'll need
to do is kind of look at what is
recommended by
that manufacturer the most important
step in your freeze-dried process is the
way that you pre freeze your sample
shell freezing is the best because
you're going to get a thinner sample and
that way it will speed up your liable
ization process you do want to pre
freeze to a point below your sample of
eutectic temperature it is very
important that your sample is 100%
frozen prior to putting it onto the
freeze dryer if you could have sample on
the freeze dryer that is not 100% frozen
it will immediately start to melt back
and that's not a good thing for the
process the rate of free pre freezing
will determine how your sample lye
applies as Kelly mentioned faster pre
freezing typically creates smaller ice
crystals larger ice crystals are formed
by a little bit slower process of freeze
drying and then you can also do the
annealing process where you pre freeze
to a maximum temperature and then bring
it up just the load the samples eutectic
temperature to prevent melt back a lot
of people think that during primary
drying especially when you have control
of your product shelf temperature that
colder is better and Kelly mentioned
that you do need heat transfer to those
samples in order to speed up the
freezing the free strike process alaska
lighting process what you want to do on
a shelf is typically bring it about five
to ten degrees below the sample eutectic
temperature in order to get the
optimized speed of your lab life process
if you look at a tray dryer or a clear
chamber with shelves you'll notice that
the front product the front vials are
going to have more radiant heat than the
back file so that's another thing that
you have to keep in consideration if you
are looking at endpoint and you notice
that the front vial seemed like they
look like they're freeze-dried you
you do want to keep going a little bit
longer to account for the samples that
are insulated in the middle flaps will
use room temperature as their heat
transfer there's not much you can do
about that in a flap however you can
insulate them if it seems that it's
taking a long time to freeze dry or if
your samples are starting to melt back
you can also insulate them to block the
UV light
the optimum conditions for your life
Eliezer and we've seen this a lot
there's been a couple times when I go
into a lab and the lab lies are sitting
right in front of a window and it's
Florida and it's July so you do want
your room to be relatively cool about 22
degrees Celsius if a room is too small
it's going to get too hot in that room
so your sample could melt you don't want
to be it directly under a heat vent and
your freezer needs to be close to your
freeze dryer you don't want to take a
sample from a different building again
in July and Florida and walk it from one
building to the other building where
your freeze dryer is because those
samples obviously could melt during that
walk so if your freezer is located close
to your freeze dryer it really is a
better alternative some customers like
to use a bulking agent if you look at
the outcome of some samples you'll get
different results so the middle picture
is a nice cake like sample but every
once in a while you'll get a sample that
kind of collapses and it doesn't look
like a pretty cake bulking agents or
stabilizers will help fast if you have a
sample that is temperature sensitive you
can use what are called leiyo
protectants and those help protect those
samples we get a question often about
cGMP for lyophilizer and I'm going to go
through this very quickly basically
according to the FDA the manufacturer is
really not in control of your specific
cgmp you can actually purchase Ally
eliezer from lab con CO and make it fit
your cgmp requirements that would be
done on your end but what lab con co can
give you is we can give you the
materials of construction all of the
test reports that have been done on your
specific freeze dryer we have the
manuals the links to videos
different literature specifications
three-part sex we also offer IQ OQ to be
done by yourself on your freeze dryer
and if you do need PQ we can give
recommendations to outside consulting
groups so we're happy to give that as
you if you need it some things that I've
seen in my 17 years at Levchenko would
be some challenging samples one of those
samples that we see often would be
tert-butyl alcohol what happens is you
end up with a gummy end product you also
see this with oils where you don't get a
nice cake you get more of a gummy
product at the end that doesn't dry 100%
so just something to keep in mind
alcohols have a very low freezing point
so they can sometimes be difficult to
keep frozen so you'll have a frozen
sample you'll put it on the freeze dryer
and it'll melt back that's why you must
dilute an alcohol sample if you can
evaporate it off prior to putting it on
the liable Iser that's that's a good
thing because then you don't have to
deal with diluting you also need a minus
105 freeze dryer in order for you to
have the temperature differentials DMSO
is a very common solvent that we're
seeing more and more often and it freeze
Rises it freeze rise nicely but it will
attack your rubber and plastic
components anytime you need to pull a
deep vacuum you have to have rubber
components to keep that vacuum feel one
thing to keep in mind with the NSO as
well as DMS that's another solvent depth
that will start attacking the rubber on
plastic components you just may need to
replace your gaskets over time when you
start seeing cracking or brittle gaskets
sugars and salt have very low eutectic
temperatures as well so you want to look
at a minus 84 freeze dryer if you are
doing sugars and salts and you also want
to look at a HEPA filter because
especially with sugars they tend to you
get particulates in your vacuum pump
you can start to damage your pump so a
HEPA filter will protect your vacuum
pump soil samples that's another thing
that could migrate into your pump so
again you do want to look at a HEPA
filter to prevent that migration into
the pump when you're looking at whole
samples such as a blueberry something
with a shell or a grape you want to
either homogenize those fruits and
vegetables or if you can poke holes in
that skin or peel the skin and if you're
doing animals which is becoming more and
more common again again you want to poke
holes in that skin just so that that
vapor can leave those animals and not
get tied up with anything binding it a
couple things people common problems
when you're looking at troubleshooting
if your samples won't stay frozen make
sure that you are using the correct
freeze dryer look at the sample size
obviously if you have a small sample
it's going to melt a lot quicker than a
larger sample and look at every aspect
of your sample could it help some
alcohols
could it have solvents could it have
salts or sugars and then make sure that
your vacuum pump is pulling at the
correct depth if samples are being
sucked out of the vial by the vacuum you
can either use filter paper or parafilm
and that's going to help keep those
samples in the vial if they're taking
too long to lie applies again is your
shelf temperature too cold or is your
sample too thick or is there something
blocking that vapor path that's not
allowing the samples to or the vapors to
leave if the pressure is not low enough
and vacuum issues are probably the most
common problem that we have with a lie
optimizer check everything on your unit
we have a video to vacuum troubleshoot
it's also in the manual you can also
call our product service group and
they'll walk you through it or we might
need to get a service or in to determine
if something internally is causing that
issue sometimes you're going to notice
that the final product looks different
time-to-time and what that what that
could be is your initial solvent is
colder than it was the day before or
warmer than the day before there's a lot
of different things that can cause that
cake to look different from time to time
did you have too much active ingredient
you have too little active ingredients
if you have a cake versus a powder it
could be due to the solvent that you're
using or it could be due to your active
ingredients that it may not form a nice
cake they can also be due to how you pre
froze those samples so the outcome is
very normal for you to get different
outcomes even in the same batch on the
same freeze dryer doing an oil change is
very important so you don't destroy your
pump you saw in a picture a rusted
rotary vane pump that pump was destroyed
in about two to three weeks so it
happens fairly quickly which is why you
need to do regular oil changes check
your sight glass make sure your oil is
clean so few think different things to
do and the gas balance helps keep those
solvents clean you want to open or close
it to vent out any contaminants that got
into that pump and we do recommend doing
it after each run and more of that
information can be given either through
our website or if you want to ask us
directly we're happy to explain how that
gas ballasts work so that you can extend
the life of your pump
okay so that's all I have and hopefully
we don't take too much of your time but
we're happy to answer questions thank
you both for your presentations before I
begin the question and answer session
poll question will appear on your screen
you may select your answers and close
the question by clicking on the X in the
right corner and the question is will
your laboratory be purchasing a
freeze-dry in the future also the
speakers have provided additional
information for you and so it is time
for Q&A if you have a question you'd
like to ask Kellie Williams and or Jenny
sprung please do so now just click on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for the first question
is my freeze-dry sample melts within 30
minutes of being on the freeze dryer
what should I do differently well as we
discussed in optimizing the process
there could be a couple of things that
you want to look at specifically what is
your sample are there solvents are there
alcohols and then we would need to know
which breeze dryer you have because you
may have the wrong freeze dryer for what
you're trying to do and our next
question is I need to stop or a small
number of samples under vacuum what is
the most economical way to do this we do
we do have other accessories we have a
mini stopper in chamber or else a a
stopper chamber where you can turn the
handle yourself and stopper so there are
some economical ways to do that with a
free Schreyer if you cannot can't afford
to buy it a large stopper ring trader
Iyer
is it possible to over dry sample um
generally speaking you it it's nearly
impossible no one really had it or when
you say over dry I assume that you mean
keep it on there too long that has never
been a problem so
depending on your application
there really isn't when you're free
strong you're wanting to get all the
moisture out so we haven't run across
anyone that's ever over dried their
sample we we've seen under drying of a
sample but I've never seen over drying
of a sample if you under dry a sample it
will actually start reconstituting
itself
the next one is I run a few samples a
month that vary in size and can never
tell when they are completely dry do you
have any suggestions well if your
samples are in flasks and you're getting
ready to get a new system you could get
our new end zone endpoint determination
accessory that will tell you it will
actually alert when your samples dry so
it makes it very easy to know when it is
finished if you have an older unit or
you're doing trays one thing that you
can do is close the valves or isolate
the tray dryer from the collector and
see if the vacuum pressure changes as
long as you're undergoing vitalization
you're producing baser molecules that
will affect the vacuum level so once you
close the valve if your vacuum decreases
that will tell you that your sample is
still being freeze-dried the next
question is do large crystal to damage
our samples that's a great question that
I should have mentioned when I was
covering it earlier for if your sample
the chemical sample it is not going to
damage it however if people are working
with cells and or tissues and they're
trying to freeze dry the goal for that
pre freezing is to you to have it form
small crystals so you're going to want
to freeze dry it fast so that the
crystals are smaller and they they are
not going to be disruptive to the cell
membranes or so all you have
recommendations for handling potential
pathogens um that is the question that
we get a lot and is you're going to have
to involve your safety officer there are
some things in it in it all is going to
be dependent on your situation and the
pathogen itself however there are hepa
filters that will go between the
collector in the vacuum pump and you're
going to want to put a HEPA filter
inline and deal with those pathogens
before they reach your pump for sure a
lot of people
we'll put them isolate them in a
biohazard style cleanroom but certainly
addressing it as small as possible as
early in the process as possible is more
preferred than having a bigger issue by
not addressing it early
are there any available charts or tables
for you Petach temperature collapse
temperature for commonly used solvents
yes I mean yeah textbook out sorry
Shelley we do have a eutectic
temperature chart that was in the
presentation in terms of the collapsed
temperature it really depends on what
you're adding to it because obviously
most people are not doing pure water to
freeze dry it's a matter of what you're
adding to it
I would like to want you to think sorry
please ask oh if you go back earlier in
the slides those eutectic charts were
were included I would like to once again
thank Kelly Williams and Jenny sprung
for their presentations do you have any
final comments for us today no no we
thank you for joining us and for the
great questions if we did not get to
your question go ahead and send it in
and we can email you we appreciate your
interest in the products Jenny did you
have anything nope I appreciate you guys
are joining us well thank you both once
again I would also like to thank our
sponsor Lemkin Co for making today's
educational webcast possible this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January 27 2018 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye